Let's fix the issue of determining when
we should transition to the second
view controller.
We can do this by changing the segue
to only be called from code, and
not to directly by the storyboard when
we pressed the stop recording button.
We know that we're recording our voice
that records sounds view controller.
Once recording is finished, we need to
send that file over to the second scene.
The play sounds view controller.
How do we change the current segue
to be called just by code and
not from a UI button?
If you look in the main
dot storyboard file here,
we can see the two scenes
are connected via a segue.
In particular this segue's wired
up to the stop recording button,
every time this button is pressed,
Storyboard will perform the segue.
What we really want is to be able to
call this segue programmatically,
once we know that the AV audio recorder
has finished writing out the file.
This is easy to do,
let me walk you through it now.
Let's start by deleting
the current segue,
select the segue here in the document
outline, and press the delete key.
Xcode will complain that
the second scene is unreachable
since we have no way to segue into it
from anywhere else in the storyboard.
You can see that warning in the Xcode
status bar here, to fix the warning and
set up a segue that we can
control programmatically.
I'll hold Control key and
drag from the first View Controller
to the second View Controller.
The easiest way to do this is
from the document outline.
I'll expand the view
controller scene here so
that I can see both view controllers.
>From the record sound view controller,
with the control key held down,
I'll drag into the view controller and
select show segue.
Now that these two scenes are connected
via segue, we can have the storyboard
perform the segue by calling
a function named perform seg.
We'll set up the perform seg call
shortly, but in order to distinguish
this segue from any other one,
we need to give it a unique name.
Select the segue here in
the document outline, and
in the Attributes Inspector,
let's give it a unique identifier.
I've given it the name stopRecording,
these names are case
sensitive by the way.
Make sure you spell it correctly.
Next we need to know when
AV Audio Recorder has finished
writing out the recorded voice file.
To do that we need to use
a concept called delegation.